hơi nghi, bán tổ chức trung hương đã không vô quyết định của vô chính trị.
Về việc điều động chỉ điện động chỉ hoàn văn nghiệp,
bí thư tình vì là sơn giới trước bí thư tình vì sân la nhận kỳ hàng nhé không trong hay lâm,
hàng nhé không trong bà mời, tương ngày mấy lâm tháng mời năm, hàng nhé không trong hay lâm.
Phát biểu nhận nhận vụ, động chỉ hoàn văn nghiệp, bí thư tình vì sân la,
bây toa cảm ơn xấu sắc đến vộ chính trị, bán bí thư bán tổ chức trung hương đã tính nhận ra chọn chắc mới,
động thời kăng kết sẽ luôn nỗ lực hết mình tận tâm tận tuy,
nếu các tính tiến pong vương mấu, vừa vững nền tắc của đàn,
nói đi đôi với làm, phát biểu vai cho là hạt nhân đoàn kết,
cùng tập thể quyết tâm thực hiện tháng lợi các mục tiêu,
khi quyết đại hội đàn bộ tình lành thứ 14 giẩm kỳ hàng nhé không trong hay lâm,
hàng nhé không trong bà mời đã đe ra,
có phần cùng cả nước thực hiện tháng lợi quyết đại hội đàn phòng của bà,
tướng tới đại hội đại biểu phòng của bà của đàn thứ 14 của đàn.